welcome to today's webinar before we
begin
we wanted to cover a few housekeeping
items for any common technical issues
please refer to the help widget located
at the bottom of your screen
if you have any questions during the
webcast you can submit them through the
q a widget
questions will be answered immediately
following the presentation
any resources and links provided from
today's presentation can be found in the
resource list
an on-demand version of the webcast will
be available approximately one day after
the webcast
and can be accessed using the same
audience link that was sent to you
earlier
all right so welcome everyone to today's
webinar on reinforcement learning
very excited to have you here um
reinforcement learning is a fantastic
research area that is seeing a lot of
great progress but before we get into
the details of
what reinforcement learning is all about
i want to say just a few words about
myself
in the top four corner there you see a
snapshot of my team
which together with me works usually in
cambridge in england
in this beautiful building that you see
here and my team and i
share the conviction that if within the
gaming space reinforcement learning will
make it a big difference and so a lot of
the research that we do at msr in
cambridge
within the gaming and ai organization
is looking at reinforcement learning
with potential applications in the video
game space
one of the projects that my team has
developed is project malmo
which is an ai experimentation platform
on top of the game minecraft and so it
unlocks minecraft as an experimentation
platform
for rl and other artificial intelligence
research
but let's dive right in reinforcement
learning can be very briefly defined as
a principled approach to decision making
and learning
under uncertainty and this type of
approach decision making under
uncertainty
is something that occurs in a wide range
of
everyday situations as well as a wide
range of applications
so if you think about all the choices
that you need to make every day
a lot of those can be framed as a
reinforcement learning problem
for example where to go for dinner
when to study and when to
enjoy leisure time what
course of study to take etc all of those
are decisions
where the outcome is uncertain and where
you need to understand how to
make those decisions under these
uncertain situations
but let's take a more concrete example
here in the video game of minecraft
we are here looking at the game
minecraft from the point of view of an
agent
that observes a screen here from a first
person perspective
so we model this agent as being directly
embedding
embedded in the game and experiencing
the game
from a first person perspective the
agent needs to interact with its
environment so we model this as taking
actions
in this environment for example here the
agent might decide to move forward
towards the zombie that it's facing we
also typically assume that there is a
reward signal that the agent can learn
from
in this case nothing exciting happens so
we can assume that the agent got a
reward signal of zero
and then this concern uh this continues
and you can think of this as a cycle
where the agent observes the next
observation
it takes an action so for example here
it might issue the attack command
it re receives some reward signal in
this case again of zero
and it obtains the next state so we can
play this forward and so here we come to
an example where
the agent observed a non-zero reward
signal
and we can think of reinforcement
learning as this principle approach
that needs to um understand or that
allows the agent to learn
what the consequences of its actions are
in complex
environments and then given that
understanding of the consequences of his
actions
how to continue to interact with an
environment in such a way
that it maximizes its own reward its own
long-term reward
and so one one interesting observation
here is that
even though this reward of plus one in
this case was closely associated with
the
kind of attack action that we think had
uh kind of played a big influence on
getting this reward
because we actually hit the zombie um in
many cases
the reward that is associated with
various actions the agent has taken
may in fact be delayed so it might take
a very long time for the consequences of
the agent's actions to actually pan out
and so we run into this problem of
having to understand
how to learn consequences from the
stream of data
of the agent continuously interacting
with its environment
so even in this simple example we can
see some of the key
challenges that we face when we try to
come up with principal approaches to
solve
reinforcement learning problem
formulations the first one i already
mentioned
is about how to attribute consequences
to the sequence of previous actions and
states that the agent has encountered
so for example here we may want to
attribute quite a big
contribution to this attack action in
this specific situation
but maybe moving forward so that the
agent is placed in the right position to
attack
also played a role in getting this
positive reward and so how should
the credit for those various choices and
be distributed over those action
sequences
and most importantly how should this
change the agent's behavior policy
so that it's able to get higher reward
in the future
now this problem is typically called the
credit assignment problem and it's one
of the key challenges in reinforcement
learning
there are two other key challenges
typically we want
reinforcement learning algorithms to
interact in domains that are
complex so for example here the agent is
experiencing its world
from this first-person perspective where
it observes
high-dimensional pixel images so how
should it
interpret those observations in such a
way that
again allows it to perform credit
assignment
even in situations where observations
are high dimensional
and this is typically called the
function approximation problem
and finally we need to understand how
the agent
should interact with the world so what
kind of behavior it should actually
perform
given what it has already learned and
given that it wants to continue to learn
about the consequences of its actions
this is the third key challenge in
reinforcement learning
and it's also referred to as the problem
of balancing exploration and
exploitation
so briefly we want to ensure that the
agent continues to explore alternative
courses of action so that it can learn
about their consequences
while also making sure that it exploits
what it has already learned
so that it can benefit from that
knowledge and get high reward as it is
interacting with the environment
now this relatively straightforward
problem formulation has a huge
number of potential and actual
applications
in the real world so just to mention a
few of those
in a healthcare setting we might
formulate the problem of deciding what
treatment to prescribe to a patient
as a reinforcement learning problem
where again the consequences of a
particular course of treatment
are uncertain given the current
knowledge about the
patient's symptoms in a
science scenario or discovery scenario
we can model the problem of deciding
what experiments to run in what order in
order to continue to learn as much as
possible we can imagine transport
settings
where for example we might want to time
signaling in complex transport settings
or as already mentioned in gaming there
is a wide host of applications
including to understand how games could
be more engaging could create new
experiences to their players
in the lecture today we will be looking
at
initially in the first lecture some of
the foundations of reinforcement
learning
starting very importantly from an
understanding of how to formalize
reinforcement learning in such a way
that we can derive principled approaches
to this problem
we'll be looking at the first set of
such approaches which are based on
the benmen optimality equations and the
approach we'll be looking at is q
learning
and we'll come back to the problem of
balancing exploration and exploitation
finally in this lecture i want to
conclude by taking a look at
what the stage rewards and actions
typically
are for an agent and just make clear
that those are very important design
choices
that need to be well understood when
someone wants to apply reinforcement
learning and practice
i'll take a short break here just to see
if there's any questions
do we have any questions so far
no if someone still wants to sit in the
front and there's still some
space here all right all good so far so
let's continue
um starting with reinforce formalizing
reinforcement learning i want to just be
clear that um this formalism is not just
a way of putting nice pictures on the
slide here
but it's really important because it
lets us very clearly specify
our assumptions about how an agent
interacts
with an environment in this particular
setting
it allows us to make simplifying
assumptions and those simplifying
assumptions are really crucial
for then deriving efficient algorithms
for solving reinforcement learning
problems
so as we already saw in reinforcement
learning an agent is modeled to interact
with an environment
we typically model this agent as having
the goal to learn an optimal behavior
policy
and the policy is typically some
distributions over actions given the
current state observation
we typically assume that the environment
that the agent is interacting with
is initially unknown and this is a very
important assumption because it makes
the problem a lot harder
if we had a perfect model of the
environment we could reduce the problem
to a planning program
where we can work out all the
consequences of the
agent actions without actually
interacting with the environment
we already saw the kind of basic
framework of how the agent interacts
with the environment
we assume that agents interact by
sending actions
from some action space a and in return
the agent observes
some reward signal which is typically a
single scalar
as well as a state observation in some
observation or state spaces
to complete the formalization here the
agent is assumed to act with a policy pi
that maps state states to actions so
it's a probability distribution
over actions conditioned on the current
state observation
and we model the environment as having
the following dynamics and reward
function
again importantly those are unknown but
we assume
that crucially the transition dynamics
that govern
the environment tell us that the next
state that the agent will find itself in
will be a function only of the previous
state and the action taken at the
previous time step
and that the reward function again is a
function of again the previous state and
the previous action
and this assumption is very important
it's the one
crucial simplifying assumption that led
to a lot of progress in reinforcement
learning over the past decades so let's
look at this assumption in a little bit
more detail
we can summarize the formalization that
i just mentioned
in the tuple shown here on the screen
which is typically called a markov
decision
process so it's a markov decision
process m
which is defined by the state space the
action space
the probability distribution over the
transition
of the environment the reward function
as well as a discount factor
gamma given this
definition of a markov decision process
we can write down
the goal of our agent i already
informally stated that the
our goal is to develop an agent that
takes
actions that get the highest long-term
cumulative reward
and here we can write down this quantity
in more detail
we typically formalize this as a return
gt
so it's the return that the agent can
obtain from a time step t
and it's the infinite sum of rewards
that the agent can collect at every time
step
and this sequence of rewards is
typically discounted by this discount
factor gamma
which is typically a number that is um
less than one but typically very close
to one
and it captures the intuition that this
potentially infinite interaction between
an agent and the environment
has some nonzero probability of stopping
at every point in time
and so you can think of from this
discount factor as modeling
the probability that the interaction
between agent and environment will stop
and this makes it important for the
agent to get to potential
rewards sooner rather than later because
if rewards are very far in the future
there might no might be no time to
actually collect those rewards
um now the crucial assumption that i
already alluded to here
is the marcroft property and as you saw
in the previous slide
the markov property makes the
simplifying assumption
that the environment dynamics and reward
function
are purely a function of the previous
state and action
this is simplifying the problem a lot
because it means
that whenever we work out an agent's
policy we only need to model
um the distribution over its actions
given the state we
can we don't need to maintain the entire
interaction history between the agent
and environment
which allows us to develop much more
sample efficient algorithm
this understanding of the markov
property and its importance to
initially planning goes back to richard
bellman
for example his paper in 1957
already pointed out the importance of
the simplifying assumption
and baman played a crucial role role in
deriving
some of the initial understanding of how
we can address
complex decision-making problems
initially in the form of dynamic
programming
and now a lot of the reinforcement
learning approaches we use today
go back to some of those initial ideas
that were developed in this context of
planning
under in the dynamic programming setting
right this concludes the formalization
of reinforcement learning are there any
questions up to this point
yeah problem it's exactly the same as
what we call generic dynamic programming
kind of we use the dynamic program to
show the planning problem that is
exactly right yes
exactly he there's an interesting story
about why he picked the term dynamic
programming he wanted to
not get anyone to notice that he was
actually working on mathematics so
there's an interesting story there
yeah the definition of states and the
transition dynamics
is done in priority so
the um definition of states is something
that is under control of
the person who applies reinforcement
learning or who formulates a specific
problem as a reinforcement learning
problem
the transition dynamics are an
assumption that we make about the
environment
so when we apply for example what's
called model-free reinforcement learning
approaches
we don't explicitly model the transition
dynamics we just assume
that the environment is governed by
dynamics that are
markov or approximately markov which
then gives
us an insight on whether our approaches
have any hope of actually working in
that environment
even in the case of model 3 the states
will need to be defined
yes that's right um and so that that
would be a choice that is under the
practitioner's control and so the
practitioner or for example someone
working with the domain expert
would have to understand what for
example
state features the decisions rely on
and they would need to make sure that
all the information necessary
to make a decision in that particular
domain
kind of is captured in the state in the
state space and that's
as as you mentioned that's an important
aspect of formulating the the problem as
a
as a reinforcement learning problem in
many situations it actually is possible
to make the problem
fully observable like we're assuming
here and using the markov property
in some settings that might not be
possible and then
you're in a different formulation which
is called a partially observable markov
decision process
where you need to smooth over the
history for example
but we won't be going into detail on
that today
yeah so the more conversational process
you described is the screen right
analog um this there's a lot of
continuous analog so do you mean time
discrete or do you mean the state and
action space
right so with function approximation in
general we're not limited to a discrete
state in action spaces and
apart from the initial examples in the
tabular setting
all the approaches i discussed but in
principle
generalized to a continuous state and
action space
there's some caveats in the sense of
continuous action spaces are usually a
little harder to explore we'll get into
some of those details in the in the
second lecture but in principle
reinforcement learning as a problem
formulation doesn't care whether the
problem is discrete and continuous
and in fact batman initially was
focusing on continuous
problems before people in the
reinforcement learning community started
to look more at the discrete
equivalence the question what about
continuous time sagan
what about continuous time um yes in
principle
there it's possible to formulate it as a
continuous time problem
it's it's
harder to actually do the rl problem
right so if you have something given in
terms of differential equations you can
work out solutions
in relatively simple cases and so in the
control theory community those problems
are quite common
um without additional assumptions
those are hard from an oral perspective
we
can follow up offline but it's not
something that is currently looked at in
the
in the kind of mainstream oral
literature
is there any reason you chose minecraft
as your domain
that's a really good question um
minecraft is a fascinating game because
it's a meta game and so
one of my kind of long-term research
goals is to develop
rl agents that are able to learn lots
and lots of tasks with relatively little
additional
data and so minecraft is a fantastic
test but for that because
we can kind of get humans people to
create essentially any
number of tasks in there it's something
that players already do they create mini
games they play with their friend
and so by tapping into that we actually
essentially have the whole richness of
that environment
as a playground for reinforcement
learning agents
all right thanks for the fantastic
questions discussion um
i'll move forward with looking at
birmingham optimality and q learning
so now that we've formalized
reinforcement learning
as in this case an instance of a markov
decision problem
we can look at approaches on how to
actually approach
how to actually solve this problem the
examples i'll be giving
in this section are relying on project
mamos so here's just a quick overview
if you want to try some of the examples
that i'll be showing
project mimo is an open source platform
it's available for free on github
and so you can download this and try
this out at home
the example that we're using to
illustrate
queue learning is a minecraft rendering
of a classic reinforcement learning task
called cliff walking
and within project malmo this is the
tutorial 6
if you want to follow along um just a
quick reminder in this environment we
can see
the agent with an environment that is
initially assumed to be completely
unknown to the agent so the agent starts
with
no knowledge of what the various
blocks mean in this environment even
though we can of course visually see
what's going on there the way the agent
interacts with this environment
is that in this case we start from a
tabular representation
so every block that we see that the
agent can
move to is modeled as a distinct state
and the agent has four actions available
so at every point in time it can move
north south east and west the reward
structure
as you can imagine is negative when the
agent
falls in lava and the agent observes a
positive reward
when it navigates all the way to the
goal so our
goal here is to have an agent that
learns to navigate to this
positive reward with as few samples as
possible
we can actually illustrate this
relatively simple example
in the form of what is called a cue
table and in this tabular representation
we see
a cell here for every block that the
agent can navigate to in this
environment
we also see that each block here has a
little circle
and this circle indicates both the four
actions that the agent has available at
any point in time
as well as our current estimate of how
good the given action is in that
particular state
and we'll see in just a couple of
minutes that this is called
a state action value or value so we'll
come back to this concept very shortly
and we can see in this tabular
representation here
the current state of knowledge that the
agent has so far so we can see
that it has some estimates of the
quality of the actions that it can take
in this area
and that area but large parts of the
environment
are still unknown and it doesn't have
any estimates of how
good its actions are in those and in
those parts of the environment
now if we run an algorithm called
q-learning
given this current knowledge that the
agent has
this is what we see
so as you can imagine because the agent
currently does not know what the
consequences are
of visiting those various state action
pairs that we see here
it is prone to falling into lava and
getting that negative experiences
and experience of what it's like to fall
in lava
now how can we get the agent to actually
learn
how to behave in this environment as
already mentioned a crucial concept in
the setting
is the so-called q value or state
action value which is
defined here so our q value under a
given policy pi
for the current state st and the current
action 80
is defined as the expected long-term
cumulative reward
that the agent can obtain when taking
action a
a t in this particular state st
and based on the formulation of the
agent's goal
that we saw earlier we can actually
write this as this expectation
under the current policy of the
long-term discounted cumulative reward
just as we saw
previously now
the key insight or key insight that
bellman actually contributed to the
community when he was working on dynamic
programming
is that there is a recursive
relationship
um hidden in this definition and that we
can actually make use of this recursive
relationship in order to efficiently
solve reinforcement learning problems
the recursion here is that the the
task of finding an optimal policy can be
formulated as the task of finding
the initial optimal action and then
following some policy moving forward
and that is exactly the recursive
relationship that he discovered
so we can move to this by first writing
out
this expectation here as the sum
of the immediate next reward plus the
discounted expected reward for the
remainder of the sequence
so all we've done here is that we have
taken apart this infinite sum we have
chopped off the very initial element
and then we have written this out as the
sum of this element
plus the remainder of the sequence
this can be just looked at visually here
this gives rise to a very important
concept called
backup where the recursive relationship
allows us
to model the return from every state
action pair
as the sum of the immediate reward
obtained
plus the remainder of that sum
and we can calculate this remainder of
the sum because we have an estimate
an initial estimate for all the state
action pairs in our domain
um so for example going back to our
minecraft example
if we want to work out the value of the
action a t in this particular state we
can
take a step in this direction here
observe the one step reward we get for
that transition
and then back up back up to our estimate
of the value of this follow-up state
that we have at this point in time
and this is an approximate iteration
which can actually be shown to converge
to the correct q values
for a given domain and initially that
was
shown by bellman for the dynamic
programming setting so initially not yet
for the reinforcement learning setting
where an environment simulator might be
unknown
so this is one of the kind of key
insights in reinforcement learning
that this recursive relationship can be
used to work out the values
of all the state action pairs in the
given domain
and baman's book from
1957 this does
get into a lot of detail on this and
really describes key
insights that form still still form the
foundation of reinforcement learning
today
now how do we get from this recursive
relationship to an actual practical
algorithm that we can use to solve
reinforcement learning problems
even when we don't have access to a
reliable environment simulator
this um kind of a set of effective
algorithms
including q-learning are called
are based on an insight called temporal
differences
again temporal differences are based on
the recursive relationship that bellman
illustrated earlier and we can look at
the temporal difference error
on the slide here so if we look again at
the q value for given state st
and given action 80 and look again at
this
relationship then we can rewrite
or we can write a specific error called
delta
if we compare those two quantities so if
we imagine we are in a situation where
we need to work out the values for all
state action pairs
eventually this difference here should
be precisely zero because as we've shown
previously
we can exactly write the q value in
terms of
the sum of this immediate return plus
the remainder of the
reward sequence now if we have an error
this quantity is called a temporal
difference error and
a wide range of reinforcement learning
algorithms actually relies on the fact
of minimizing this temporal difference
error
all the way until the sequence of
iterates has converged to an error of
zero
a very effective algorithm for doing
this
initially in the tabular setting was
developed by
watkins who was based in cambridge in
the uk so
it's a good place for reinforcement
learning and it has been for since the
80s
and a sketch of the algorithm is shown
here so
here we no longer assume access to a
perfect simulator of an
environment and instead we really have
an agent interact
with the environment step by step
briefly to go through this for each
episode
we initialize our state space and then
from a given s we choose an action a
using a policy that is derived from q
here's a brief note that an example of
such a policy can be an epsilon greedy
policy
this connects to this problem of
exploration exploitation that i
mentioned earlier
and we will look into more detail of
what possible alternatives are
in just a few minutes but for now it's
enough to say that an epsilon greedy
strategy
follows the maximum q value most of the
time but has some
non-zero probability of taking
exploratory actions at every point in
time
in order to make sure that the agent
has a probability one of visiting
all state action pairs in the limit of
interacting with the environment
so the agent has chosen an action it
takes this action and observes
the reward and the next state and then
the update rule to the q values follows
exactly the recursive relationship that
we have seen earlier
so we back up our
updated estimate of the q value by
taking some learning rate alpha times
our immediate reward
plus the gamma-discounted
maximum q value for the next state that
we could find ourselves in
and as you remember the temporal
difference error
this quantity exactly minimizes the
temporal difference
error on the state action pairs that the
agent encounters
not only did what can some develop this
algorithm he and peter dyan were able to
prove that q learning is guaranteed to
converge
to the optimal policy in the discrete
state action setting and so this was a
really important insight here
so let's look back at what q learning
looks like in mamo
this is what happens after training the
algorithm for about 10 minutes and you
can already see
that at this point we have a much the
agent has a
much fuller understanding of the state
action values in the given environment
we can now see that by following its
current policy
it still takes some exploratory steps
and doesn't take the shortest path to
the goal
but it has found a safe
passage to the goal and is able to
achieve high reward
on this task
let's take a few yeah let's take a few
minutes for questions sure
it's a model three in this case or we
can consider that it's a model based
because we're kind of
building this model
so the traditional definition of model 3
would be that this is a model free
approach
this q value representation that i'm
showing here
is something that um i use to to
visualize
the uh q values but um
the um transition dynamics
of what this actually means aren't
actually known to the agent it's
something we can project into because we
know the arrangement of blocks
but it's not knowledge that the agent
would make use of
yeah so
the agent got the lava experience so is
there a way to reduce the number of
times the intention
experiences the lava
consumers right right this is really at
the heart of
what it means to make reinforcement
learning more applicable in practice
typically in order to reduce the number
of samples required for learning
means that we need to either make
additional simplifying assumptions
or we need to provide some initia some
additional knowledge or some additional
information
and that additional information could
for example be
an initial policy maybe some a
demonstrated policy by an expert or by a
baseline algorithm
that we could take as a lower bound that
would be one way to inject
kind of expert knowledge in order to
allow for more
sample efficient algorithms we could
make
additional simplifying assumptions or
structural assumptions about the
transitions
of the mdp or basically anything we know
about the environment can be formalized
as constrained or some other form of
knowledge that can make
learning faster
any other questions before we move on
yes sir this is off policy because
when it is learning it is not following
specific initialized policy for
that's a really good question so i
haven't mentioned the on policy of
policy kind of distinction yet
q learning is an off policy algorithm
and it's called that because what it
learns about is the optimal policy
not the behavioral policy that it
follows so as you recall it follows
what's called an absolute
greedy policy but it actually learns the
estimates for
the optimal policy it could follow if it
were to take the maximum
action uh maximum value action at every
state
yeah so during this example how do you
define state
this is a state correspond to a grade in
this
yes and this particular one in the in
the kind of tabular formulation we
assume that every cell is a
but then i wonder since your learning
process happened only at the beginning
part of the
sum of states it's not clear to me
how would you extrapolate that to the
states that you haven't seen
that's a very good question um and it's
exactly one of the limitations
with this tabular formulation um in this
tabular formulation there's no way for
the agent
to use experience from let's say similar
states to learn about the consequences
of actions in other states
and this is where we need to move into q
learning with function approximation
which is a an approach for generalizing
two unseen states that are similar to
what we've seen
so the example before showed is actually
not what
actually use some technique you have to
talk about the example i showed
does not generalize over states so
that's why
um as uh you call it the character can
move ahead
and avoid that and get the reward right
so you must have used some technique you
haven't yet covered
right so far this is i've covered all of
this
so we have used epsilon gradient
exploration
to work out the state action value of
every single
um state action pair separately and the
agent in this case did not generalize um
over those
um the only thing i've done is i've
shortcut i haven't shown you the entire
10-minute learning process
and i've jumped straight to the end but
under the hood all that exploration
you know over the course of 10 minutes
yes yes exactly i've only showed you the
first three episodes but yeah imagine
that that this went on for you know the
agent died in lava a couple of thousand
times before it got to this situation
great question yeah um you mentioned
that like convergence is like always
possible in a discrete state space
what the optimal solutions always
require like brute force going through
every presentation of every state action
pair
possible in your q table or is there
like optimizations possible to not
happen right
so all the guarantees that i am aware of
assume that the agent can visit each
state action pair
infinitely often in the limit and all
those are convergence proofs in the
limit of infinite data
as was mentioned before you could if you
know something else about the domain
you may be able to derive an approach
for
a subset of mdps or for this specific
constraint problem you have
um you may be able to get guarantees
there but those would be less general
and so then it would be
kind of you have to look on a
case-by-case basis what are your
assumptions and what does that mean in
terms of convergence guarantees for
example
one more question was that um in this
specific domain
do you have like an api for figuring out
the state or is this like computer
vision on top of that
yes so within project manual we have the
concept of
observation handlers and so with
observation handlers the experimenter
can pick and choose
in what way it wants to ex in what way
they want to expose states to the agent
so there's the tabular representation
here it could be vision it could be the
death map there's
you can get chat from other agents etc
so there's a lot of choice in terms of
how the program is formulated in this
particular point of time
yeah so the notion of discounting it
feels like
you're kind of limited to exponential
discounting and the way the recurrence
is set up yeah that just feels like
there's like a form of bias
like um is there any way to work with
rights
that's a really good question so it is a
recency bias
and so the the kind of intuition there
is that it's better to get rewards
sooner rather than later
there is research on this martha white
has looked at a more general form of
discounting
she published on this in the last two
years so i see melon europe's in the
last two years
so there there definitely are people
thinking about this but it's not
something standard it's something that
is
only coming up now
all right um let's let's move on
so oops let me get big here
um so as you may have already noticed um
with the
tabular representation that we've seen
before
the agent can learn very effectively
in relatively small state action spaces
but there is a key limitation that the
agent is not able to generalize
to unseen state action pairs and so with
the tabular representation it would need
to visit
all state action pairs in order to learn
about the consequences of taking actions
in those particular states a type of
approach
that aims to get around this limitation
is what's called q learning with
function approximation and so
the key idea there is that instead of
building up the table of
q values explicitly for each state
action pair
we learn a function approximator that
approximates the state action values
instead
the change from tabular queue learning
to
equilibrium function approximation is
conceptually
quite straightforward and you can see
that this relies
again on the notion of a temporal
difference error
we see exactly the temporal difference
error that we formulated before
but now in a function approximation
setting we can use this temporal
difference
error as an objective where we need to
minimize
the loss we minimize this temporal
difference error
by updating the parameters
theta of our function approximator and
so you can for example imagine
the function approximator to be either
a linear function of our state action
features
or for example a deep neural network and
so we would
here have a very straightforward recipe
of what we need to do
to update the parameter vector of our
linear function approximator or the
parameters of our
neural network in order to minimize this
particular error
in terms of practical implementations
minimizing this error is as simple as
using a current deep learning framework
and actually minimizing
this objective using stochastic gradient
descent
i will highlight in just a few moments
that even though conceptually simple it
took
um quite a lot of research to understand
how
um um actually how to actually
implement this and get this to work well
in practice
took quite a few insights because what
we're doing here is essentially
taking reinforcement learning which
is a highly non-stationary problem the
data under which we
minimize this objective changes over
time as our exploration policy changes
and this leads to instabilities compared
to if we were to do this in a supervised
learning setting
where the set of data that we learn from
is fixed ahead of time
but before we kind of take a closer look
at some of the pitfalls and
solutions there let's just look at an
example of where we
translate our earlier minecraft domain
into a problem where we can
actually learn with q learning and
function approximation
we see our minecraft agent here in a
similar maze environment
um in this one here we actually trained
this agent to navigate
arbitrary mazes so even though the
location of lava in this case is fixed
we can vary this over the course of the
environment
what you see here in the top left corner
is the actual observation that the agent
receives
so this in this case are the four
previous
frames that the agent would observe from
a first person perspective
and we can see here in this corner
the current q value estimates of the
agent where we see a very
large negative estimate for the action
of moving forward
which is a very sensible estimate given
that the agent is actually facing a pit
of lava at this point in time
running the agent policy we can see how
it's
moving around the environment and how
its
q values are changing as it navigates
the environment
you can see here that whenever it faces
a clear path the q values are all
positive
and whenever it faces lava it is able to
generalize and very effectively model
that there is a dangerous situation it
shouldn't get into
so i want to just briefly summarize what
we've seen so far
we have discussed reinforcement learning
as a principal approach to decision
making and learning under uncertainty
and we had a very quick overview of
three of the key challenges that we
faced
in reinforcement learning the credit
assignment problem of how to attribute
consequences to previous states and
actions
and we saw an example algorithm or an
example approach of how to address this
for example q-learning um we need to
in higher dimensional settings
understand how to interpret
observations and this is done using
function approximation
we saw an example of doing this with the
deep neural network or linear function
approximator
and finally we need to understand how to
act given current knowledge
we saw a first approach to balancing
exploration and exploitation
in the form of epsilon greedy and we'll
look at more examples in just a second
here
so so let's look at the final piece of
the puzzle how to actually act in a
situation where we need to balance
exploration and exploitation
um i'm starting this with two examples
and i
you to take a look and just think
through um what possible choices you
might make in those situations
in the first one you face a series of
slot machines
where someone told you that these slot
machines might have different payoffs
but you don't know which ones those are
and what kinds of payoffs they have
how would you decide which one to play
next
um what if i told you like in
in this situation that the current q
value estimates are like this
what what kind of could you make use of
that information
so we're in a different situation here
these are the q values that the agent
has already worked out
given those what actually should i pick
if i have
a hundred steps left to go
to their hundreds so you can try either
you can
you can try on any of them
so that's that's a really good point
here so we assume that the experiment
doesn't terminate completely
an assumption about democratization
processes that i didn't discuss was
that the assumption is usually that the
mark of decision processes we interact
with
are ergodic which means that from any
given point in time we can reach
any other state action pair in a finite
number of steps
and so this means that we never have uh
kind of we assume that there is never a
catastrophic failure there is never a
situation
where the experiment ends and we don't
get to continue and
this is an assumption we need to make in
order for any of the approaches we know
to actually work
like minecraft probability you can
actually die
right um so it's modeled as an episodic
setting in an episodic setting
it's an alternative to discounting so
you can
typically either assume that you have a
continuous sequence of interactions and
there's a discount factor smaller than
one
or you assume that there is a terminal
state at some point
at which you will typically break that
series of iterates you just update to
the
present terminal value and this again
allows you to have a finite
um basically both of those make sure
that you're that your
sequence of rewards is bounded in some
way
all right so after you have thought
about this for a couple moments and
developed some intuition
of what the various choices are for
balancing exploration and exploitation
in those two settings
let's take a look at a few of the
choices that people are commonly using
in in practice the first
very simple approach is something called
optimistic initialization
and the principle of optimism is one
that is often
often quite simple to implement in this
particular form
and can lead to very good behavior
optimistic initialization in our earlier
tabular example
means that whenever we encounter a new
state action pair
we assume initially that the value of
that state action pair is high
and if we know for example that our
rewards are bounded from above
then we can make a very informed choice
of how to initialize
state action pairs that we haven't yet
encountered
this is as mentioned a simple approach
the only
drawback is that it assumes that we have
some estimate of the upper bound of the
of the reward function
um even with such a simple approach
there's still quite interesting
interactions between
the initialization approach and the
underlying optimization problem when we
move to
reinforcement learning with deep
learning with function approximation
and this is one that we came across last
year
when we were looking at understanding
exploration
in deep reinforcement learning we run
experiments in a domain that is called
the mountain car
problem this is a quite famous
experimental setting
in a reinforcement learning in the
reinforcement learning literature
and it's modeled as this underpowered
cart which is kind of starts at the
bottom of a value
valley and it has to navigate all the
way to this
star here the card is underpowered which
means that
it needs to go back and forth between
those two hills up to the point where it
has enough momentum
to actually reach the target here and
this is often taken as an example of a
hard exploration problem
because the agent is assumed to not
observe any positive reward
until it reaches the goal position here
so it's something that requires
strategic exploration
in our experiments we found that
depending on the function approximator
use
we can learn or an agent can learn this
problem
purely using optimistic initialization
and no other exploration at all but this
behavior very much depended on the type
of function approximator
used in the case where we used a linear
function approximator
the agent would not encounter the
target state and this is represented
here in the
diagram that shows the coverage of the
states the agent encounters during
learning
we can see that those are all
concentrated here near the middle of the
plot
whereas the goal position is indicated
by this red line over here
and so we can see that in the setting
with linear function approximation
the agent never encounters the gold
if we keep everything as the same but we
use a deeper
neural network function approximator
then depending on the architecture
used the agent is able to actually solve
this task
it's able to do this the most
efficiently when we use a two hidden
layer
neural network with relu activations and
we can see here that the agent
learns very quickly and in the way the
kind of optimization of the neural
network parameters works out
the agent is actually drawn to the
states that give it high reward and so
this is some one example that is not
quite yet
explained by what we know about deep
reinforcement learning but it's just an
interesting example where we see that
exploration exploitation together with
deep function approximation and
reinforcement learning
has interesting interactions that can
either hinder or help
learning in those particular settings
looking at a couple of other approaches
to exploration exploitation that are
common in the literature
this is the epsilon greedy strategy that
we have already mentioned
in this setting we take the
maximum the current maximum value action
with some probability 1 minus epsilon
and we distribute the remaining
probability
mass of epsilon on the remaining actions
so we can see that in our earlier
example with probability epsilon the
agent would take this maximum action
and it would distribute the remainder of
its probability mass
uniformly across those two actions based
on this example you can already see the
advantages and drawbacks of this
approach
an advantage is that the approach is
easy to implement as long as we can
easily derive the maximum action from
our value function approximator
but we do not have any ability to
learn additional information about the
actions and so for example catastrophic
actions would be taken
just as much as actions that are very
close second to the current
maximum value action
another popular alternative that is that
commonly used with a type of approach
called policy gradient reinforcement
learning
is a so-called soft mix policy a softmax
policy is a particular
parameterization of the agent's policy
in the form of a softmax function
and so we can interpret here the
function h
of s a as an action preference so
how much better do we estimate the
action a to b than the other alternative
actions in that particular state
this is exponentiated and then
normalized in order to give us a
probability distribution
over actions for a given state and so we
can think of this as this transformation
shown here at the bottom
this is really nice because the learned
estimates
for example if we think of these h's
here as
something that is highly correlated with
our current q value estimates
then we get a very natural way to trade
off between actions that have
um that have high potential value versus
so that those that have low value
there is typically a hyperparameter in
the form of a temperature parameter
that can be used to provide additional
information into how steep that
trade-off should be
how steep the decay should be between
high value and low value actions
a fourth type of approach is an upper
confidence bound
type of approach which models the
uncertainty the agent has
over its current value estimates so if
you imagine that in addition to the
just expectations over the state action
values
that i showed you earlier we instead had
some estimate
of our confidence then the upper
confidence
bound type of approach would take the
action that maximizes an upper bound and
so for example if
there's a higher uncertainty on this
action that has a slightly lower
estimated value
than the winning action then this
approach would um take
this this action in order to learn more
about the consequences
of taking that action this type of
approach
has very nice properties in theory and
is guaranteed to converge very quickly
if we are able to derive principled
uncertainty estimates
and this is commonly possible in a
simplification of the reinforcement
learning setting called
abandoned approach where there are no
long-term consequences of
of of actions in given states but it's
typically much harder to derive such
principle estimates
for the full reinforcement learning
problem so while not
is called available sampling and again
it relies on maintaining
our maintaining a distribution over
state action values
instead of just the expectations assume
here
that we have a model of the full
posterior
distribution over the estate action
value estimates
a posterior sampling approach would at
any given time step
take a draw from those posteriors
and then it would work out the optimal
action
given the draw from that distribution so
for example if you
if you imagine sampling from this
this and this function then there's some
probability that the values that we
sampled
for this action is higher than the one
that we sampled for this
and this would give us some distribution
over how we actually allocate our
exploration budget in this particular
setting
um this concludes our discussion of
exploration exploitation in
reinforcement learning
so just to quickly recap we addressed
the problem of credit assignment
function approximation
and the problem of exploration and
exploitation
when moving to deep reinforcement
learning we typically
get a lot of interaction between those
different components
so for example we might get interactions
between
representation learning so how the agent
generalizes over different state action
pairs
with either uncertainty explore
estimation
and exploration exploitation and we saw
one example of that
another way in which these typically
interact is in the stability of
training i already mentioned that under
the hood in deep reinforcement learning
we ask the agent to solve a optimization
problem
that for all purposes um
kind of takes the form of a supervised
learning problem however we are in a
non-stationary setting where the data
available to the agent continues to
change
um finally a key challenge is sample
efficiency when actually learning the
credit assignment
and they're typically when we have when
we require a large number of
environment interactions there are
new interesting ways in which people
make use of that data
in order to speed up the optimization
problem
just to look at some examples of the key
insights that were developed as
part of the work on dqm so the work
where
it was first shown that deep q
networks could be applied to learning a
wide range of atari games
these this approach managed to
stabilize q-learning in the function
approximate
approximation setting with two key
components first of all the authors
stabilized deep neural network training
by using what's called
a replay buffer so a large amount of
previous environment agent interactions
were stored in this replay buffer
that was only slowly changed over time
and all the q learning updates were
based on batched samples from that
replay buffer this stabilized training
because now the data distribution
would only change slowly and the rate at
which it changed could be controlled
the second innovation there was that a
target network was used
in order to work out the
q value targets that were used when
optimizing to minimize
the temporal difference error again this
target network
was only changed slowly over time
again with the view of slowing down
and stabilizing training in the
setting of q learning with function
approximation
great i will be skipping the discussion
of
choosing states and actions and rewards
and i want to take
about a 10-minute break if you have any
other questions on any of the material
here or if you want to
discuss some more about how to choose
state actions and rewards
when applying reinforcement learning and
practice i'm happy to take that offline
thanks so much for your attention so far
[Applause]
i think we can continue as an example of
decision making under uncertainty
i'll make the uncertain decision to
continue with the material i had for
this
first lecture i think we'll have enough
time and we'll get through the material
for the second lecture as well
and i did want to show you some of the
material here
so let's take a look at what actually
happens when we
want to apply reinforcement learning to
a new problem
there are some key design choices that
the experimenter or prediction
practitioner needs to
need to make and this is in contrast to
the frequent kind of perspective of a
reinforcement learning researcher
who often is hindered a reinforcement
learning problem that is already
formulated
in terms of state action spaces and
reward function
and where their focus is to come up with
new for example more sample efficient
algorithms
when we apply rln practice we actually
need to make those choices
and those choices have very important
implications for how likely
we are succeed in terms of finding an
algorithm to effectively learn
in those settings so let's start with
the stage observation or state space
this is an
important modeling choice because it
essentially
lets us formulate how we're representing
the problem to the agent
we already saw two examples of this in
the material so far
we saw a tabular representation in the
form of a queue table
where algorithms give us good guarantees
but where we run into the limitation
that
agents without function approximation
may not be able to generalize
over unseen state action pairs and so
they are stuck having to explore
all possible state action pairs which
can be prohibitive if we are
in a large environment with many states
we also saw the choice of looking at for
example
high dimensional pixel observations and
that gives us the advantage that now we
can use a function approximation in
order to generalize to new state action
pairs
at the same time we run into the problem
that we're essentially using super rest
learning under the hood and now we need
to deal with
this complexity of
trying to stabilize training in a
setting where
the underlying data and the underlying
training targets
are actually changing over time in
addition to that
we get an additional problem that the
um for example state action value may
not be perfectly representable with the
function approximator we chose
for example if we use a very simple
let's say a linear function approximator
we may have to the the optimization
under the hood we
may need to make trade-offs in terms of
how accurately it can represent
the various um state action values this
can lead to
aliasing and that can also slow down or
hinder
learning in those settings so whenever a
practitioner
makes a choice of how to formulate the
problem they need to
take into consideration for example
whether
in their formulation in their particular
problem the markov property is satisfied
or maybe if they need to
provide additional features that that
make the problem fully observable
and allow them to use the machinery that
we have discussed so far
they may want to make choices about how
prior expert knowledge could be encoded
so for example
they may make choices about what parts
of the state space are actually
visible visible or can be visited by the
agent
and they need to ask themselves what the
effects are on the optimized solution
or on data efficiency i won't have time
to go into all of those in detail and i
just want to give a few
thoughts based on previous literature
and
how the kind of choice of state
observation space might work out
as already mentioned the work on dqn the
demonstration of
learning with function approximation
from pixel images
was a very impressive result because it
for the first time demonstrated
that learning in a reinforcement
learning setting
with function approximation could
stabilize enough
in order to make use of learning with
function approximation and so the team
under miadal impressively demonstrated
that
given enough data such a deep q-learning
algorithm was able to learn to play
atari games
at or above human level
however at the same time the algorithm
was very data inefficient it required
millions and millions of samples in
order to achieve that very high level of
performance
and so in this study that i really like
which was um led by
w in 2018 um looked at
what the difference is or might be
between
how humans interpret and play or learn
to play video games
and how an algorithm like dqn
might learn to play those video games
the way they did this is they created
a version of a video game here a
platformer game
that they manipulated in various ways in
such a way that
either human players or a dq algorithm
would observe
the state of the game with a different
type of observation and they examined in
detail how those different observations
would affect
learning ability of humans or dqm agents
and so this is a really nice way to look
at
how those what what kinds of priors
humans might use when they learn to play
video games
this is an example of a playthrough by a
human player
in the vanilla version of the game so
you can see it's a platformer game we
need to collect keys avoid open monsters
avoid
spikes etc the first manipulation they
used was to mask the semantics so
instead of having those the pictograms
as seen in the
original version of the game under
masked semantics
the um uh kind of indication of what
kind of object
i might be dealing with was actually
masked out in this situation
we can see by looking at the results
that humans
found it harder to play the game in this
setting
whereas interestingly a deep
reinforcement learning agent
was not affected by this manipulation at
all
this gives us the insight that humans
might use those semantic prayers when
they learn to play a new game
whereas deep reinforcement learning
agents for better or worse aren't able
to use such a prior
which slows down their learning in
practice but also doesn't hinder their
learning
when semantics aren't provided as part
of the observation
as a next step the authors masked out
the identity of objects
so whereas here in the original game we
have gaps between
monsters so walkable area versus
specific objects in the environment the
identity of objects here was
masked out in the sense that all of them
were replaced by colored blocks
again for human players this made it
much harder to learn to play the game
whereas deep hue learning agents were
not affected at all
again this gives us interesting insights
into why
humans are so much more efficient when
we learn to play video games
in their kind of vanilla version
the most extreme manipulations that the
team did were to
mask out affordances so there was no
more no longer an indication of
what might be objects what you could
interact with
in this environment and finally they
even masked out similarity
so while here you can still see that
platforms have the same color
this similarity is completely removed in
this most extreme treatment
where similarity was masked out as you
can imagine
these are increasingly harder and harder
to play by human players
but only one of those manipulations was
actually affecting the learning ability
of a deep q-learning
agent do you want to guess which of
those manipulations actually affected
dqm
who says the last one um who says
c okay if you have the right intuition
there so
uh d exactly my similarity is affected
why do you think that was the case
the intuition is that there is no
similarity between the state
um there's one more uh level of detail
you can go into
um dqn actually uses a deep q network
which consists of convolutional layers
and then fully connected layers
and convolutional layers are exactly
encode a bias
that essentially encodes visual
similarity
and so here the effectiveness of
convolutional layers
would be reduced and the network would
have to
learn a lot more filters in order to
capture similarity within that scene
really good insight so moving on from
the choice of state space to the choice
of action space
again the choice of action space is an
important modeling choice
which can for example include the use of
discrete actions so for example whether
um a button is on or off or which button
to press as is the case in atari games
and we might be naturally in continuous
domains for example in a robotic setting
um this might include how
include how much force to apply towards
joint
and the kind of modeling of more
kind of complex and more interesting
action spaces is an ongoing and very
interesting area of
current reinforcement learning research
this includes for example
action spaces that are very large or
complex
combinatorial action spaces spaces that
mix for example discrete and continuous
actions
and in the limit as a very extreme
example the use of
full natural language as an action space
traders of this choice include data
efficiency so you can imagine the larger
action space the more actions the agent
has to explore so the more
sample inefficient any algorithm is
going to be
that is especially the case in
continuous actions where usually
um the agent has to or kind of the
decision of how to explore
is a lot more complex so typically
continuous action spaces
are more sample inefficient to learn
and the trade-offs you also include
generalization so for example
if the practitioner were to discretize a
complex action space
then their choice of discretization can
affect
how effectively the algorithm can
generalize over
similar actions in that particular space
just to give you one more example of how
researchers are pushing the state of the
art and reinforcement learning
here's an example of a platform for
research
where the researchers are trained to
push research in using natural language
as the action space for reinforcement
learning
um this is a research platform developed
by people at microsoft research
including msr montreal
and based on this text world platform
they ran
a competition last year to
understand how effectively reinforcement
learning agents are already able to
make use of various ways of modeling
natural language and generating
and understanding full natural language
this takes the form here of
text based games which is a really nice
and interesting domain
where a lot of tasks can be generated
using the textbook platform provided
here insights that they have
kind of gained so far already are that
a lot of the recent work on language
modeling
is really helping reinforcement learning
agents so while there is still a huge
room for improvement here
researchers are starting to make
progress in understanding how our
agents might be able to operate in a
really text-based world
finally i wanted to briefly touch on
this question of where the reward
actually comes from
this is one of the most crucial modeling
choices because
the underlying kind of assumption so far
has been
that a practitioner is able to develop a
good reward function for the able for
the agent to follow
in such a way that maximizing reward
finding an optimal
policy with respect to that reward
function actually gives the experimenter
the desired behavior
policy in some cases there might be
natural choices for this so for example
in an atari setting
the choice of game score might be a
natural choice
but even there we see that specific
forms of for example normalizing that
score
can have really strong effects on how
efficiently the algorithm is actually
able to
to learn some of the challenges there
include
that it is hard to learn when the reward
signal is very sparse
so for example in a setting where the
agent is able or needs to be able to
achieve a given goal
it might be very natural to give the
agent a positive reward when the goal is
achieved
but waiting for the agent to
accidentally come across that goal
can take a very long time and can be
very sample inefficient to learn
another consideration is usability so
again a practitioner needs to be able to
formulate this reward function
so let's pick some intuition on how
strongly the choice of reward structure
can actually affect a reinforcement
learning agent
and to do this let's look back at the
example of
a tabular queue learning agent learning
the cliff walking task here within the
project mimo
minecraft environment just to give you a
quick reminder
earlier we saw that with the default
reward structure that we
provided here the agent is able to learn
this task
very quickly for example after about 90
training episodes
or just a few minutes of training the
agent is able to solve the task and
obtain the diamond
at the end of this navigating this cliff
so now let's take a closer look at the
reward structure that we actually used
for learning here
there are three types of rewards that
we're defining here as part of the
project mimo
task definition and first of all if the
agent encounters a block of lava
it gets a strong negative reward signal
of -100
and this also terminates the episode if
it
manages to find the diamond at the end
of the platform
it gets a strong positive reward
thinking of plus 100 and again the term
this terminates the episode and on all
other steps the agent gets
a minus one step reward which is
designed
to encourage the agent to find shorter
and shorter paths as it learns to
navigate this platform but now what
happens if we were to change this reward
structure
so for example over here we have
replaced
the minus 100 negative reward for
encountering lava
with a minus five reward and so you
might think that's a pretty minor
modification
and we have actually ensured that in
principle the optimal behavior
is still the same behavior of actually
navigating to the diamond as quickly as
possible
but we can already see that this
relatively small change in the reward
structure
has dramatic effects on learning the
task in contrast to the default reward
structure
where the agent successfully learned the
task within less than 100
training episodes here if we train the
agent 400 episodes
it is nowhere near solving the task and
it actually falls in lava
very very frequently you can also see in
the queue table
that the agent has not yet covered the
entire space
um and and is still learning more about
the different effects and consequences
of its actions in this environment
a similar picture after 200 training
episodes
again still the agent has nowhere near
converge to the optimal behavior
and this continues after 300 episodes
in this example so we can see that even
minor modifications like the one
proposed here can have dramatic effects
on
how quickly an agent can actually learn
a task
and as we move to more complex
situations for example tasks where
function approximation is required
picking the right reward structure can
make the difference between
getting an agent to learn this task
successfully and entirely failing
on learning that task a lot of
reinforcement learning expertise and
experience
are needed to construct these effective
reward structures
and that is true even for those simple
scenarios but even more so
in more complex applications so we can
see that
as we try to move reinforcement learning
towards more and more realistic
real-world applications constructing
reward structures
and debugging them can be a serious
obstacles towards reaching those wider
application areas
just to give you a quick pointer many
promising ideas and research directions
are currently being explored to address
this challenge of
creating ways to more easily defining
or maybe automatically learning reward
structures
that can be used to successfully train
agents
to complete complex tasks one
project where we have recently addressed
this challenge
is the mineral competition following up
on this idea of
learning from demonstration this
research direction has inspired
the minor rail competition that we have
recently run
at the neurops conference this
competition is a close collaboration
with a wide range of partners
and led by william goes at carnegie
mellon university
the goal here is to provide an
environment and a set of data
that is able to facilitate and catalyze
more research into
sample efficient reinforcement learning
by building on knowledge that can be
extracted from human demonstration
i want to conclude with a short video
that gives an overview of this
competition
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
the mineral competition has now
concluded and i
would very much encourage you to check
out the links i will show at the end of
this lecture
for details of the winners of the
competition and the very exciting
solutions
towards more sample efficient more
generalizable
reinforcement learning using human
priors that these participants have
developed at the same time challenges
such as sample efficiency learning
using human priors or demonstration data
and other questions about how to
learn efficiently for example in more
complex
settings including multi-agent scenarios
are wide open research questions
and i'm strongly convinced that we will
see a lot of progress over those coming
years
not in small part driven by more
open and more complex experimentation
environments becoming available
in combination with more and more data
that can be used for actually driving
innovation in this space as part of this
picture
project malmo is an open-ended
experimentation platform
that can support research progress on a
wide
range of experimentation scenarios and
research
directions such as the ones mentioned
previously
all right results of this first
computation will be made available
at the neurops conference if you're
interested in learning more about the
competition we will be including
relevant resources and pointers with the
webinar materials so do follow up on
those
just to summarize the mineral
computation has a lot of demonstration
data
and our goal here is to understand how
to best leverage that demonstration data
in order to achieve more sample
efficient reinforcement learning
algorithms
i hope you have very much enjoyed the
lecture today
and if you're eager to learn more or try
some of the things that you have learned
about today
at home here are some pointers to get
you started
first if you are watching this live
there will be the opportunity
to participate in the live q a right
after this webinar
and i'm very much looking forward to
your questions
if you would like to learn more about
reinforcement learning
one way to get into more advanced topics
about this area
or to check out my tutorial that is
available in recorded form from the
neurops 2019 conference
and you can check that out online if you
would like to learn more about the
exciting work
that i am doing together with my team
and other collaborators
as part of the microsoft research game
intelligence group
i encourage you to check out our
websites our website where we have
pointers to blog post and some of our
latest research articles
we used a lot of examples from project
mamo today
and as mentioned project mamo is a very
general purpose experimentation platform
that opens up the video game of
minecraft
for constructing ai experiments
including a wide range of reinforcement
learning experiments
if you would like to learn more check
out the links that are shown here on the
slide
and last but not least i gave you an
overview of the mineral competition and
how it is
using an innovative experimentation
setup to drive research towards
sample efficient more generalizable
reinforcement learning algorithms
while the competition has closed the
exciting uh results and
insights that we obtained from our
participants
are now provided on the website so do
check that out
thank you so much for listening in today
hi everyone thank you so much for
attending the seminar on
exploring reinforcement learning methods
from algorithm to applications
um and our live q a i'm katya hoffman
and over the next 10 to 15 minutes i'm
going to answer
some top questions that you have
submitted today
let's get started our first question is
about
what makes a problem formulation and
reinforcement learning
markov or alternatively in what kind of
settings we would see non-markov
formulations for example with partial
observability
an easy way to imagine a problem where
the markov assumption does not hold
because
you have partial observability is if you
imagine an
agent that explores the world from a
first-person perspective
so for example imagine a robot that has
a mounted camera and needs to navigate
through some hallway it can only use its
local observation so it may not see
what is behind the next door it has to
navigate to the space it may require
memory in order to
maintain all the information about the
environment that is necessary to solve
the task
in many real-world applications however
there might be choices that a
practitioner can make in order to
make a problem more fully observable for
example in the hallway problem it might
be possible to include an overhead
camera and that might provide additional
information
that might make the problem more
tractable
another common example is in the
benchmark
that is posed by the atari learning
environment
there if the agent needs to learn from
pixel images
if only a single current pixel image is
provided
then that might not give enough
information for example to estimate the
speed of moving objects
however if the agent is provided with
several frames at a time
which is called frame stacking then the
environment might be
near fully observable and the markov
assumption might hold or might hold
approx
approximately so this is a really kind
of nice way to think about
when you are solving a real world
reinforcement learning problem to really
carefully think about
how the observation space is defined
what kinds of assumptions can be made to
hold or to hold approximately
that might make learning easier in that
setting
um another set of questions that came
into or that
that came up today a lot is about um
changes over time so for example
what if we are in an mdp where the
reward function
or the transition function may change
over time
in the most general setting if we can
make no additional assumptions about the
problem
then this might be intractable so for
example if you imagine
a setting where the reward function
changes arbitrarily over time
there may not be enough structure for
the agent to learn anything meaningful
at all
however in many real applications we can
make
additional assumptions and there are a
lot of really interesting problem
formulations that
extend the mdp formulation to very
specific non-stationary settings
that can be very useful in practice so
if this is
a type of problem that you're facing
that i encourage you to look at the
literature to see
what people have developed one example
formulation
that makes very restrictive assumption
and as a result might be very powerful
is the base adaptive setting
so this assumes that an agent interacts
with a class of mdps
that are related to each other through a
very low dimension
a piece of hidden information and when
the agent interacts with a given mdp
it can uncover information that allows
it to make
an inference about which task it's
currently interacting with
and so this is a very powerful framework
it imposes a lot of
additional structure in such a way that
the agent can
deal with um the changes that it might
experience over time very effectively
the next question that we've gotten
is um where do you see the set of next
readable applications of reinforcement
learning
there a set of reward applications that
i'm already very excited about
are using a restricted formulation of
reinforcement learning that is called a
context to a banded setting
for example the azure personalizer
service
is a product where these this type of
reinforced metering is already used very
effectively
for example to personalize or adapt for
example
news websites to individual users
john lankford and rafa houdin drove a
lot of that really exciting work and
they have a recent microsoft research
podcast
about this topic and the exciting
research that is making this possible
so if you're interested in this type of
application area
i encourage you to take a look and
follow up
with for example listening to this
podcast
i strongly believe that in the longer
term reinforcement learning will
completely revolutionize
how we think about computers and how we
interact with them
i believe that applications and video
games are really exciting application
to test out to that future and this is
why my team and i are so
focused on using reinforcement learning
to test out and develop new experiences
within the video game space
so that's something i'm hugely excited
about
um we're starting to wrap up the last
question for today
is going to be around research
directions in reinforcement learning
so the question we have here is what do
you see as
important research directions for
reinforcement learning
my team and i are really motivated by
developing reinforcement learning
algorithms that are effective
in practical real-world applications so
we really ask ourselves
and what are the problems the
fundamental problems that we need to
solve
in order to enable the next generation
of reinforcement learning algorithms
and that's a reinforcement learning
applications and as mentioned
many of those we initially see in video
game applications
um one key limitation that is often
hindering
river applications today is sample
efficiency
and some of our recent work in this
space
has been looking to improve sample
efficiency of rain for
enforcement learning algorithms for
example by developing
better abstractions by exploring more
effectively
and by developing algorithms that can
generalize better
to new subsets of reinforcement
learning problems we're also really
interested in applications
um or new algorithms
for multi-agent reinforcement learning
settings
in many real-world applications a
reinforcement learning agent will not
act in some kind of vacuum but it will
interact with some human users
and their developing multi-agent
approaches
is really really crucial we believe that
multi-agent reinforcement learning
problems have some very interesting
structure that can be exploited in order
to develop
effective and efficient algorithms for
those challenging settings
and that's something that we're really
pushing at the moment
with that i want to thank you all for
attending today we really appreciate
your participation the interest and the
fantastic questions
that you have sent on the subject if
you're interested in learning more we
have listed some great resources
in the research list resource list to
the right of your screen
this includes for example a pointer to
my recent
europe's tutorial and i would recommend
this as a great way to follow
up on this webinar because it goes in
more detail
on some aspects that we've touched on
today and also discusses some of our
latest research
if you are interested in the research
that we're doing here at the game
intelligence group
in the cambridge lab there are also
pointers to our group
as well as to some exciting blog posts
about some of the research that we have
published very recently
we look forward to seeing you build on
this research and develop
new insights in reinforcement learning
and in particular we're looking to see
some of those ideas
applied in practice with that i wish you
a great day